il faut rester sur
tout le monde les wade doug
and his words animaux dont des mots ni
ma famille ni for french morning
light sorti des masses tu as qui effraye
nous voyais cette ombre aux gels et a
toutefois renoué avec annecy - f1 mais
dit
il a vu des horreurs et il dort pas
parce qu'il sait qu'il va se passer
encore des horreurs le 15 août 2021 les
talibans un mouvement islamiste armé
traîne le contrôle de kaboul la capitale
de l'afghanistan
déjà au pouvoir en afghanistan entre
1996 et 2001 puis chassés par l'armée
américaine les talibans ont une
interprétation très stricte de la charia
la loi islamique issu du courant rahman
est donc un réfugié afghan qui est en
france depuis juillet 2017 nous l'avons
rencontré chez lui avec sa femme
française rabanne est retourné cet été
en afghanistan pour une urgence
familiale retour sur son histoire et sur
un voyage qui a viré au cauchemar mais
pour commencer avec le début vous avez
grandi en afghanistan et il ya huit ans
vous avez quitté l'afghanistan c'est ça
qu'est ce que vous faisiez en
afghanistan et pourquoi du coup avoir
quitté l'afghanistan il ya huit ans je
te
sécurité avec un mari qu'un
haut que j'ai changé ma dope
après j'ai pris
iphone john dowland ambassades de deuce
verra son nom à ce problème
mais groupe bordeaux nord
et en europe oui très fort on sait où et
américains wolfang louis xii santé
entre 2008 et 2011 il travaille pour les
forces spéciales américaines et en 2010
il se rend à la base militaire de
koundouz situer donc au nord de kaboul
sur le trajet il est arrêté par des
talibans
tous deux en hausse de 2
des
12 simples formules de camus est que
verront tout est selon raman ce sont les
talibans qui l'ont capturé pour lui
faire payer sa collaboration avec les
forces spéciales amérique dans le monde
les voit des 12
animaux doués
dire qu'en plus par une défaite effectif
le point d ascq de tokyo présent santé
john dalli des 200 fidèles ils firent
moins 10 sous la pression
des tenues assez riche et tristesse la
star ici dix autres reines à date un
été
chaud
d'eads ou déduite
skate ou
franchement aucune case ils
furent
tous nos sens thématique me disait tout
autant à bonne date un after my fathers
soutenu mme ashton
dans la technique
de production chinois et donc il
s'occupe me disent tous atteints wars
sans
accident
au portant sinon il
[Musique]
est piqué d'une
ive
nous
rose show il faut rester one man
show joue à des tas de corps nus en 2013
rahman quitte sa famille émigre vers
l'europe
un groupe rock the new blood in the
world pour
2012 il déclaré contact
au pakistan
dont ils
ont des ctt regoûtera turkish
un tout qui jette un
ralenti mon
soutien ma tenue à johnny johnny n'a
qu'un
fin 2016 les autorités belges refusent
d'y accorder le statut de réfugié entre
qu'en
france on ferait scouts de france qui
jouait préparant notre formateur
au
fret une formation en bac
pro
son match en décembre 2020 son grand
frère décède à l'hôpital un mois après
s'être fait tirer dessus dans une rue à
kaboul
[Musique]
before he was a boy who lives
afghanistan
mais brodeur ou en petit livre off comme
son
chat
le 31 juillet 2021 rahman seront en
afghanistan pour une urgence familiale
son retour en france est prévu pour le
dimanche 15 août soit le jour même où
les talibans prennent kaboul après une
offensive éclair sur place la situation
est critique
rahman contacte alors l'ambassade
française mais se retrouvent bloqués aux
abords de l'aéroport de kaboul à
woodstock en beauce en france votent
normale et à 10 ans remonte à l'an
passé
où nike en haïti huit mois brenda
woods n'en aille donc de cette région
wafa menu un gouffre à fric et au pouce
depuis la france sa femme fait tout pour
tenter de rapatrier son mari et trois
jours après la chute de kaboul aux mains
des talibans et le contact la députée de
ça inscriptions comment est ce que vous
le vivez les pays si vous êtes encore en
contact avec lui comment ça se passe à
ce moment là j'ai toujours été en
contact régulièrement avec lui sauf au
tout début puisqu'il est reparti au
plancher pour se protéger dès l'arrivée
des talibans et là bas il avait pas
internet donc je n'avais pas de contacts
quand il est revenu trois quatre jours
après
j'ai eu contact avec lui sauf que moi en
attendant j'avais déjà anticipé et
j'avais appelé ici la cellule de crise
pour le mettre dans la liste des
personnes à rapatrier contre son accord
puisque normalement les réfugiés n'ont
pas le droit d'aller en afghanistan il
voulait pas que
il voulait pas mais après ils voulaient
pas que ça se sache pas ce qu'il risque
de perdre son titre de réfugié à cause
de ça mais
moi je me suis dit quelle est la pire
chose qui meurent là-bas où qu'ils
soient ici et qu'ils perdent son site de
réfugiés et j'imagine que c'était pour
vos du goût à des jours très stressant
horrible c'était des coups de fil
partout toute la journée le 20 août 2021
rahman parvient à entrer dans l'aéroport
de kaboul qui est donc le contrôle est
principalement par les américains et
pendant deux jours à ce moment là il
tente de faire pénétrer sa famille à
l'intérieur de l'aéroport avec l'aide
des soldats français wang en
gyropode au
sommet depuis plus de
deux cent seize de ses
goûts insight geste
américain au second tour tout comme
monique en
faudra
d'autres agences
où une digue huras patins lors d'un
tournoi
féminin
with you take the blind
boys thomas
vanek the
special one week end
point ce jeu
je dis que ma famille ils ont accédé
plusieurs fois l'aéroport mais ils ont
été bloqués aux portes par les soldats
parce qu'en fait il n'était pas dans la
liste du vol du jour il était dans la
liste des personnes à évacuer mais il ya
certainement une 1000 personnes voire
plus dans cette liste et chaque jour il
devait y avoir je ne sais pas 3 400
personnes sur la liste du vol du jour et
c'est seulement ces personnes là je
pouvais rentrer
vingt-six autres 2021 un attentat
suicide revendiqué par l'organisation
terroriste état islamique frappe aux
abords de l'aéroport de kaboul en
afghanistan
l'explosion provoque la mort d'au moins
170 civils selon les autorités de santé
locales
treize soldats américains sont également
décédés selon le ministère de la défense
américain au moment dé de l'attak de
l'attentât lui étaient présents du coup
aux abords de l'aéroport il était dans
l' hérault dans l'aéroport est en fait à
ce moment là j'étais aux quelques
minutes après j'ai eu au téléphone moi
j'avais pas encore une information qui
avait eu un attentat donc j'ai pas eu le
stress de parce que j'étais en train de
communiquer avec lui et lui me disait
qu'il n'avait pas entendu il n'a pas
entendu parce qu'il était vraiment de
l'autre côté de l'aéroport il n'a pas
entendu attentat dans la nuit du 27 août
2021 la manne prend l'un des tout
derniers avion de rapatriement en
direction de la france sa famille elle
n'est jamais parvenue à entrer dans
l'aéroport son père sa mère ses deux
frères ça sert sont encore aujourd'hui
en afghanistan
chalach compte goûte enfin venu
à une nappe son match mais
brothers sisters son match où il a
inspecté
mendy
f k you are
what happened in pour nous tous people10
returning to
be ce théâtre aux
autonomistes
exemple
y assister
edun chez
ag2r gerald style noshow kandji quand -
brothers quand un an oui au foot mais
progressivement connaissent une couche
pour moi la photo
mais touche il
faudra être la bonne candidature de
monique liste brigitte poupart omd comme
pourtant tout est dit comme
first flight of the
five 6 buts
chacune
pour justin rose en moselle
dans
l'est
c'est paulette
faut
voir il faut une
personnalité family
and they live qui a fait
débat
israël et adachi
souvent stupides docteur faustus tardy
c'était moins brothers
sisters ou moins de la moitié
ce coup bas tu n'as tu es quand il avoue
n'en finissent porter
secours stade nautique froid - pour dire
tout haut la main famille tous en
ping-pong entre heroes
for france a failli nous est en bronze
j'ai les outputs frère n'y ait qu'un
chef anglais dit et est-ce
que je souffre je le sens pas là il
n'est pas là il a les pieds en france et
mais il a la tête en afghanistan et
perdre sa famille ce serait un drame
inimaginable surtout quand on sait que
la france pourrait aider encore une fois
il il a vu des horreurs il dort pas la
nuit c'est un peu comme dans les films
vous voyez on se réveille en sueur mah
lui s'est s'associé toutes les nuits
comme ça c'est de pire en pire et il
dort pas parce qu'il sait qui va se
passer encore des horaires 6 à sa
famille je me mets à sa place c'est
c'est inimaginable on peut pas
comprendre qu'on l'a pas vécu ce qui se
passe le message que
tu freines ce qu'a démenti des
fonds
macro
game int fort avec un chiffon doux tout
haut le people
patrimoniale ma famille au fringe gone
wild knights monde
des monstres
que huit minutes sur moi qui vais
matches c'est beaucoup pour
votre temps et nous avoir chez vous sur
le kiosque
fonds - franck dufour moins qu'un tu as
vécu ce groupe c merci à vous pour
votre temps et pour votre témoignage
ça ce qui se passe et bon courage pour
pour ça merci
merci
[Musique]